more than a hundred thousand americans
are on the waiting list for a
life-saving organ transplant but 17
people die every day before it can
happen tonight the story of a little boy
who cared so much about other people his
mother knew he would have wanted to help
them by giving them the gift of life in
a story only on eight she meets the
first of three people her son saved
he had such an amazing personality and
he was such a happy kid eleven-year-old
cameron parker had a sparkling smile and
a beautiful spirit despite fighting
asthma he was hospitalized a lot and had
a lot of problems his family thought
they had it under control i had just
texted cameron and i said i miss you and
he said i miss you too and
then like half an hour later he's gone
doctors at sunrise children's hospital
were able to revive him but his brain
never recovered days later i just want
him to be at peace like for once you
know
so
cameron drifted away but not before he
gave one last gift
his organs it was definitely one of the
hardest decisions that i had to make in
those final days the nevada donor
network was by their side
staff organizing this hero's walk as he
headed into surgery and encouraging them
to write a letter about their little boy
his short 11 years of life they read
that speech while he's having surgery to
the people that are in the operating
room at the same time but hundreds of
miles away lacey roberts was in her own
life and death struggle rushed to the
hospital they told my mom that you know
you want to kiss her goodbye an hour
later because we don't know that she'll
make it to the hospital the type one
diabetic had suddenly gone into organ
failure my kidneys had then started to
go
they were at 35 percent dialysis four
hours a day six days a week was keeping
her alive if it's not well managed you
lose eyesight you lose fingers you lose
organs roberts got the call she was a
match and rushed to loma linda
university to receive cameron's pancreas
and kidney somebody gave me
part of someone that they loved
and because of that i get a second
chance at life within weeks roberts was
writing her own letter pouring her heart
out to the donor's family the minute i
read lisey's letter i knew that i wanted
to talk to her months of phone calls led
to this moment there she is when the
families meet for the very first time
[Music]
if i could prevent one mom from feeling
what i felt i would do it 100 times over
again
[Music]
now cameron was able to donate five
organs saving the lives of three people
his mother wants to encourage other
parents and even adults to consider
becoming a donor she says because even
in the darkest moment you can still
choose light and life for someone else